So I'm going to try to offer
a few remarks to frame the day
and give a little context
for the arc of the day.
And I want to start with
a strong assumption, which
is that no one--
no one has as their goal
that there be poor quality
teaching at Harvard.
Students don't want
poor quality teaching.
Parents certainly don't.
Deans don't, department
chairs don't, presidents
don't, and instructors don't.
Nobody wants there to be poor
quality teaching at Harvard.
Many of you will be
thinking of those
stories, the ones that you have
heard or experienced yourself
where someone said, don't
spend your time on teaching.
It's not rewarded here.
Even the people
who said that still
want there to be high
quality teaching.
They just don't want you
to spend too much time
because they want you to
spend time on other things.
Everybody wants there to
be high quality teaching.
Another assumption-- although
for this one, we have data.
While there are many examples
of transcendentally excellent
teaching-- and I've walked
in and just sat in on classes
and been amazed, there are a
lot of moments in the classroom
and in other kinds
of learning contexts
that are sort of middling.
And there are still
some, I think,
fewer and fewer that are poor.
And so my third assumption--
Harvard can and should
offer the absolute best
educational experience
possible for students.
There's no reason
why we can't do that.
These days, like
a lot of people,
I find myself
envisioning a future
that seems sort of apocryphal.
There's a landscape that seems
kind of harsh and stripped.
And then I think hopefully
about the students.
And I think of each
one of them as a kind
of truly precious seed
that, carefully cultivated,
can change the
landscape of our future.
And I think that
when we don't attend,
when we allow poor quality
teaching to happen,
we're treating those seeds
cavalierly, and it's a mistake.
So I'm guessing that
most of you in the room,
because you're here, you share
these assumptions with me.
You basically agree that we
all want high quality teaching,
that there's room
for improvement,
and that we should
be working at Harvard
to make those improvements.
So then if we wanted
to make an intervention
at any number of levels--
at an institutional level,
at a departmental level, at a
school level, individual level,
what would that
intervention look like?
In the end, no matter what kind
of intervention you think of,
the quality of the teaching
comes down to the choices
that instructors make.
Before and during each course
or a learning opportunity,
whether it's short or
long, online, residential,
the instructor has
to make decisions,
they've got to do things.
They've got to figure
out what the syllabus is,
they get to decide what
the assignments are going
to be, and to think
about what they're
going to do when
they're actually
in the context with learners.
They're designing an
experience, and that experience
is supposed to have
lasting effects.
It's supposed to result in
new knowledge, new skills.
It's occasionally thought that
it should be transformative,
and that's a lot of
responsibility for instructors.
As so many have said,
even today, not all
are given explicit training
in the kinds of things
that they feel like
they need to be equipped
to take on that responsibility.
You'd think given that
most of our instructors
are academic, that if they had
questions about how to approach
that, they would go
to the literature
and they would try to figure
out what the literature says
and the evidence says
about how to teach well.
So it's kind of
interesting and surprising
that it seems rare that
that's what happens,
that people go to
the literature.
That brings us to the question
we're exploring today.
Does implementing the
science of learning
advance the art of teaching?
Does it?
I think there are
questions when people
are trying to decide whether
to go to the literature.
Does it improve learning?
What is the science of learning?
Where are the boundaries
of the science of learning?
Does it translate to practice?
When does it
translate to practice?
So in preparation for
today's conference,
we had a number of lunches
and dinners with faculty.
And we used a
particular provocation
to try to get
conversation going,
and that provocation
was an example
of a university that
was intentionally
built around evidence--
science of learning
and other evidence.
And Stephen Kosslyn, who you'll
hear from, and other colleagues
that he worked with,
use the science
of learning to design both the
curriculum and the pedagogy
for Minerva.
They wrote about their work
in a book called Building
the Intentional University.
And we used that
book and the ideas
in that book as the provocation
for these lunches and dinners.
Senator Bob Kerrey wrote
a forward for the book,
and you'll see that that's why
we have this upcoming keynote
panel.
The book in the
ideas in the book
really did work
as a provocation.
Sparks flew in some of
these dinners and lunches--
mostly the dinners-- where
there were heated words
that were exchanged.
Maybe it was the good wine.
People said things
about the Minerva model
that I hope Stephen will take
as evidence that the challenge
really was taken--
as a challenge and
felt as a challenge.
There were some things
said like, Minerva,
it's just creepy.
It's reductionist.
Hyperrational.
Hyper-Instrumental.
Killer of the magic.
Someone called
someone else an SOB.
Affectionately, I'm sure.
[LAUGHTER]
Some faculty suggested that
the intentional science
of learning approach is
only good for some learning
contexts.
That the reduction
of uncertainty
may be appropriate for learning
some kinds of material,
but not all kinds of material.
For some kinds of material,
many of these people--
mostly humanists-- said,
the goal is to cultivate
and engaged out.
Being too intentional
is an example
of what Wordsworth would
call, we murder to dissect.
Others, of course, were fans
of the intentional approach,
and wanted to know more about
the science of learning,
wanted to be able to take the
conversation of the dinner
and what was in the
book into the classroom.
And a lot of those
were scientists.
I hope that there
are people with all
of those views in this room, and
that we can have today candid
discussion, respectful
debate, disagreements
about these issues.
We have three goals for
these HILT conferences.
One is to promote dialogue.
And I mean real
dialogue, you know?
Actually saying what
you think, getting
to a place where we are
moving the institution
or us as individuals along.
The second goal is to provide
new examples, new approaches,
new tools that can be
used in actual practice,
teaching and learning practice.
And the third is to extend the
network of Harvard students,
faculty, academic,
professional staff--
for you all to meet one another.
And we hope that you
will take the time
to meet people who are different
from you in their role,
in their school, in
their discipline,
and talk with them about
teaching and learning.
The plenary is meant to
be the jumping-off point.
Following the plenary
session, rather than
having a Q&A here where my
observation-- probably yours--
is that you hear
from some people who
feel empowered to get up
and grab the microphone.
We are instead going to have
these series of sessions
of unpacking the
plenary, and being
able to be in a more candid
discussion with Stephen
Kosslyn, Senator Kerrey, one
with some amazing faculty
around faculty issues,
and then with students
from their perspectives.
And you'll see in the
program that there are
some more descriptors of those.
Those Are meant to be candid,
they're not going to be taped.
We want this to be an open
discussion that you have.
The second breakout
sessions are meant
to be implementation workshops.
To really be more concrete
and more workshop-focused.
So to take some of the ideas
and think of them implemented
in a series of ways.
Finally in the lunch plenary,
we come back as a community
and look backward and
forward with people
who have responsibility for
the next phase of this work.
Provost Garber, new Vice Provost
for Advances in Learning Bharat
Anand, and moderated
by Dustin Tingley.
And as you are thinking
about that forward-looking,
backward-looking,
forward-looking, what
do we want to know for
this conversation with them
about pivoting to
what the next era is,
you can send your questions
ahead of time or at anytime
during the day to
this Poll Everywhere.
And I think there's
cards on the table that
has this information there too.
So I'm going to kind
of pivot for a moment.
During one of those
dinners, a faculty member
asked me whether if I could,
if I were queen of the world,
would I insist that all
Harvard instructors design
their pedagogy using
the science of learning.
I've been mulling
this over, and I
keep finding myself using
this sort of elaborate analogy
to try to answer the question.
The analogy is cooking for
a special dinner party.
So I do realize that that
might sound frivolous.
I actually really take eating
and cooking very seriously.
Perhaps as seriously as I
take learning and teaching.
And I have enjoyed
this analogy, so I
hope you'll indulge
me and let me
kind of play it out with you.
So imagine you're
hosting a dinner party
and you want to ensure that the
food is high quality, that it's
a great experience,
that it's memorable,
that it stands the test of
time, that people might even
take things from that experience
and use it in other ways.
It could, for example,
be a 50th birthday party,
which I just had last weekend.
For this, you can think of
these different elements.
There's the food itself.
It has a nutritional value.
It can be high quality,
it can be low quality.
Let's call that the
content of the course.
This is really important.
Any chef will tell you that
the quality of the food
is really important for whether
it's going to be a good meal.
We here at Harvard
have a real luxury.
We can actually afford
to do farm-to-table.
We can take right from
the research and discovery
enterprise into the classroom.
So then you have the eaters.
They need to be able to digest
the food, and some of them
might have particular needs.
You could have someone
who has celiac disease
and gets a rash from wheat.
You could have
someone who just can't
stand the sight of raw fish.
And you want to be able
to understand where
those eaters are, what
they need in order
to have a good quality
experience, just like you
need to for the students.
Then there's the surround.
The context, the table setting.
And that can also have a big
impact on the experience.
If you can't hear, for
example, as sometimes we
hear that people can't
in our classrooms
because the audio
isn't quite right,
you can't have a
good experience.
And the experience will
definitely disappoint.
And now we get to the cooking.
So let me ask you a question--
how many of you like to cook?
Yeah.
For those of you who cook,
whether you like to or not,
raise your hand if
you prefer the kind
of baking version of cooking.
You know, a recipe.
OK, now raise your
hand if you prefer
the kind of throw in a
spice, figure something out,
more resourceful.
So it's about half and a half.
And I wonder--
I mean, I wonder if there
is some correlation with how
you think about your learning or
you think about your teaching.
So the point-- whether
following a recipe or not,
you can have great
food or bland food.
You can have an edible food.
Whether you're using the
science of learning or not,
you can have great teaching
or terrible teaching.
Whether you cook from
recipes or intuitively,
because you've been
eating all your life,
you are drawing on a lot
of implicit knowledge,
some of which is accurate
and some of which
actually biases the
way that you cook.
Similarly, whether you're using
the science of learning or not,
you are drawing on a lot
of implicit knowledge
from how you learned in
all of those classrooms
that you've been in, and some of
that is helpful and some of it
is not.
It's like biasing the quality
of the teaching because of all
that you've
intuitively taken in.
My opinion, to come
back to the question
that the faculty member asked
me, is that I wouldn't insist,
but I would certainly
recommend that you
use the science of learning.
I mean, if you imagine
a cook, if they
learn the science of cooking,
it's not going to hurt them.
It might take them
a little while
to implement what
they've learned
in a way that
feels more natural,
but it can't hurt them.
And I'd say similarly,
it is not going
to hurt you to understand
the science of learning
for your teaching.
I am also incredibly
sure that using evidence
and doing so intentionally,
whether cooking or teaching,
is better than going
through the motions.
Unquestionably just
cooking like one's parents,
unquestionably just teaching
the way you were taught.
And I think we've all been to
those kinds of dinner parties
and those kinds of
classes that you'd rather
not go back to or attend again.
So finally before I
introduce the plenary,
I want to come back to that
earlier question about what
is the science of learning?
There's not a single
discipline, and there
are these different strands.
And some cognitive science,
neuroscience, education,
psychology all makes sense.
There's also different
kinds of methods.
There are some that are more
sort of qualitative in nature,
and then there are
random-controlled trials,
and they result
in different kinds
of information and evidence.
And some people would call some
of that science of learning
and some would not.
So we could put the
boundaries in any number
of places around what the
science of learning is.
There's also a kind
of movement that
encourages people to be
systematic in the inquiry
in their own practice of
teaching and learning,
in the scholarship of
teaching and learning.
And there's a lot
of literature that
comes from the scholarship
of teaching and learning.
And there are people
in this community who
are doing incredible work in
the scholarship of teaching
and learning, whether
they call it that or not.
Like any interdisciplinary
evidence base,
a lot of people question what
generalizes and what doesn't.
And it's easy to say, well
that wouldn't work here.
That isn't important here,
whether the study was
done in a different
field or the study was
school, and I frankly
think that's a kind of cop-out.
I think you really have to pay
attention and think about it
and try things out for yourself,
and more information is always
going to be better than less.
So we tried to figure out what
we should put in front of you
to sort of demonstrate
the science of learning.
If you get your
programs out, you'll
see that there is a
table, a one-pager that
includes a whole bunch
of principles organized
in a kind of framework
around cognitive, behavioral,
affective sort of principles.
This is one framework.
There are resources
that go with that.
If you go to the HILT website--
by the way, HILT website redone.
After years and years
and years of gathering
all of the teaching
and learning resources
that exist at this university,
the HILT website now
captures them--
perhaps imperfectly,
but it is an amazing
place to go visit.
And there are resources
there for the science
of learning that are
referenced in that table.
There are books that have
done a pretty good job
of pulling all of this together
and making it operational.
And you can find them, I'm
sure, at your local teaching
and learning centers.
The other thing I'll
just say is most
of these principles have
been around a very long time.
This is not really new--
10, 15 years at least.
And some of them is
just common sense.
So they don't come
across as, wow, we're
really learning something
new when you look at them.
But the research is good.
They help people
learn better and more.
And I'd say one of the
best, simple, short versions
of a principled
set of ideas that
are operational comes in
Stephen's book, The Intentional
University.
And there's a chapter in
there on science of learning,
and it includes 16 principles.